the Joe Rogan experience but for you
saying from your perspective saying like
he he was a martial artist yeah right
for sure so then isn't that still true
without the movie [ __ ] he was a
phenomenal martial artist who's
definitely a phenomenal Marsh just
didn't compete didn't really compete
well yeah I guess that's part of it but
I mean like can you not compete and
still be at the top of a thing I mean is
that possible I don't know man you know
that's the one thing that if I was gonna
make an argument against me as a
commentator for the MMA for MMA I've
been fighting MMA like it's kind of
hilarious and I'm a commentator for MMA
yeah even though I'm a fan of it and I
know mostly what I'm talking about you
know I have that's on the contract just
know most of what you test but I know
mostly what I'm talking about when it
comes to wrestling like I've really it's
really interesting to work with guys
like Dominick Cruz or work with Daniel
Cormier Daniel Cormier in particular was
like one of the best wrestlers to ever
compete in MMA he's I know many an
active wrestling coach and Dominick does
a lot of coaching too and a lot of MMA
coaching too but both guys are so good
at breaking down the technical aspects
of it it makes you realize how little
you really know about certain
specialties you know but are they good
at will you differences are they good at
also articulating emotion and public the
public of viewpoints that's the
difference I can give expert analysis of
ground fighting yeah ground fighting I
can give expert like just just you know
not to blow my horn but I know what's
going on like the way a lot of people
know what's going on with boxing I can
tell you what's going on with jokes and
when when someone's in trouble when
someone's not and I can see it because
I've been strangled a million times okay
I know what that is I'm like this guy's
in trouble like and some people can't
see that but most MMA fighters at a
certain point in time they know most
basic [ __ ] in terms of positions and
when things are dangerous but once stuff
gets exotic like weird rubber guard
transitions or strange chokes like
people invent new chokes all time
there's always like something new that
you haven't seen before like how the
[ __ ] did he do that and you have to go
back and watch it again but do people
think how many people think that you did
fight now think anybody does you don't
think you know I know I kick boxed and I
mean if anybody looks at my record at
three
take boxing fights and I don't know how
many talk with no fights a lot probably
100 what was your record I don't know I
had two and one in kick box I lost my
last kickboxing fight but as far as
taqwa no I have no idea
I won the Massachusetts state
championship four years in a row and I
won I think was called the American Open
which is a big tournament I won I came
in second place in the US Cup that was a
big thing in that was in Connecticut and
I fought the national champion in the
finals and I thought I beat him that was
when I was like 19 20 that was when I
was at my best when I was around 21
before I tried out for the Nationals and
try I was gonna try to make the Olympic
team that's when I was starting to box
and kick box and I was losing faith in
Taekwondo I was realizing that there was
I had a distorted perception of what I
could do so it was just way you were way
more engaged with boxing than you ever
were with like I was getting beat up
yeah that's what it was yeah I would go
to these kick boxing gyms and when I
would just bought when I kick box guys I
could kick them so hard
they couldn't get close enough to box me
a lot of time so I'd kick him in the
arms I'd kick them and they'd be like
what the [ __ ] and then I could even
though my hands weren't as good as those
my legs were so much better because a
lot of these guys couldn't kick at all
so as long as we're starting at a
distance I could slam my legs into them
and they'd just be terrified like so
many guys just be just trying not to get
hurt right because if someone can kick
and you can't kick there's a terrible
feeling yeah somewhat so much scarier
than taking them because punches I feel
like you know I could get into a fist
fight
if someone [ __ ] kicks you in a fist
fight I'm done I'm getting it's just oh
well painful there's so much mass in the
leg and so they're so heavy you don't
realize how hard it is until you get hit
even just getting hit in the arm if it
[ __ ] sucks so bad yeah when someone
slams their shin into your arm you're
like [ __ ]
it's sucks dude but when I was boxing
with dudes I was getting lit up and
particularly there was this one dude
that I used to box with his name was
dangerous Dana Rosenblatt and wound up
to become the Massachusetts or the New
England middleweight champion really
good guy and I was sparring with him a
lot in the beginning he was beating my
ass and I was like damn this kid wants
to fight way more than I do because I
was already
in comedy at the time and I was starting
to realize like I got to pick one of the
other yeah and then as I was getting
into kickboxing because around 21 was
when I got into comedy right after one
21st birthday and so when I was getting
into like really in the kickboxing was
like 20 into 21 and the same time I was
thinking about doing stand-up and at the
same time I was realizing Taekwondo is
[ __ ]
not really [ __ ] but not free it's in
it's incomplete
the problem is it's incomplete if
someone knows how to box like what
someone closes the distance on you you
don't know what you do with your hands
you don't know how to protect yourself
you don't know where the punches are
coming from you're not used to it and
you have to get used to it
the only way to get used to is to learn
how to actually box and I didn't know
how to actually box until I was like 19
and 20 when I started going to these
other gyms right and then when I when I
realized I had these giant holes trying
out for Taekwondo like doing talking
with no tournaments and I still competed
in Taekwondo but less it wasn't excited
about it anymore
because I realized like this is if I
want to be a complete martial artist
like I want to follow like Bruce Lee's
teaching I found a hole in my game I
have to patch that [ __ ] up huh there's a
whole part that I thought I knew how to
do and I didn't I knew how to punch
things I could punch things hard but you
think that's boxing until someone pops
you with a double jab left hook pop pop
pop and you're like oh no what is this
nonsense when technique comes to play
but it's this lean hand uppercut you
just [ __ ] chin me with you think
that's awesome that's also because you
like you were obsessed as a human you
are you're obsessed with finding the
next level of things so you were
leveling up to like techno just became
kind of boring to you too wasn't that
because I still wasn't the best in the
country
you know I'd lost in the finals to the
guy who is this creme Jabbar I think his
name was he sounded he sounds good
he was good very good he was the
national champion you know Karim's your
bars are good
I lost a decision too but I'm telling
you I thought I won that but there was a
lot of wacky decisions in Taekwondo I
mean I definitely lost a lot of fights
but there was ones that are one that I
didn't get the decision is it a point
system yeah but it's a weird point
system it's very similar to boxing where
you know you're like you decide yeah
it's a side I never understood but I
love boxing watching my I don't get I
still don't get boxing scoring when
you're like what
they come up with these just people that
aren't good at it you know if you had
like Ali boxing judges like that's what
I used to love about like comedy judges
Harold Lederman to do the button that he
used to tell you what the score was
he would tell you what the score was you
know like so he would say this is how I
have it you know I think Rosario has
been doing the best work and he would
you know break down the fight right it
was it was part of the but was fun but
anyway I wasn't bored with it in that I
achieved the highest of heights
it was that I realized it had holes in
it like big holes huh big holes big
holes like if I was in a street fight
with one of those boxers and I was in a
bar where I couldn't throw a kick I
would be in deep [ __ ] yeah deep [ __ ] and
so I'd learned how to box
but that was right or so like my
experience my point like I'm not a guy
who should be explaining like everything
that's going on but it's entertaining
that's it like we talked about before
the show all these NFL guys are mad
because Tony Romo got a 17 million
dollar contract and they're way better
than him on the field than he ever was
on the field a lot of these guys are
getting paid way less and this dude was
you know like how the [ __ ] is this dude
getting he was talking yeah he's just
chatting well that's what makes guys
like neon Sanders neon Dion Dion he's so
flamboyant because that's where you get
money outside of just playing when the
truth is guys like Romo he does have and
this is something that you would share
his acumen for the game is so strong but
he's also like his opinions are so real
that he's not trying to save a job a lot
of times these announcers they Strine
adjust save a job you know they're like
doing the right thing being safe yes
they're there they're totally he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he'll call out an offense or
a defense and say well this is why they
[ __ ] up that last play and I think
America goes oh [ __ ] that's great that's
cool to know versus someone just going
here's the play and there's the play and
that's what happened in okay here next I
mean it just could people get bored of
the same kind of announcer what's also
his insight is gonna be so much better
than anybody who hasn't played the game
so he just came off the field yeah he's
actually that's why in the UFC they do a
great job with guys like Michael Bisping
you know it was a former middleweight
champion he does a lot of commentary now
and he's great dc-dc commenting yeah
Dominick Cruz Paul Felder who's great at
ooh yeah and all these guys that have
fought before especially at the really
highest level maybe even fought some of
the
are doing commentary for they can give
real insight as to the things this guy
does when they train for tenancies
[Applause]